early on it was really quite a verse to
stun guns and stuff he was like hey man
we're doing Bulls next week I can't wait
for Bulls but I'm really not into this
and getting shocked business but then
over the years he became desensitized to
electricity
his aversion to it went away yeah I mean
I hit him right in the face chest with
it and he was just like he grabbed the
electric eel and didn't even react yeah
yeah and those things do shock did they
really shock you yeah big time man I
remember when we did the electrical bit
thinking he isn't so affected by
electricity right and that's why I knew
it wasn't a fair fight I was like if
electricity doesn't hurt him